bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau 7,8 société ce soir nous avons
parlé d'un sujet qui n'en finit plus de
faire l'actualité le break site soit en
français la sortie de la grande-bretagne
de l'union européenne catastrophe pour
certains opportunité pour relancer le
processus européen pour d'autres les
avis divergent et sont nombreux sur le
sujet alors qu'elle portait faut-il
donner au référendum britannique va-t-il
avoir des conséquences graves pour
l'économie britannique et européenne
va-t-il aussi est-ce aussi la fin de
l'union européenne pour en parler ce
soir et répondre à toutes ces questions
philippe le guen président de
l'association jean monnet olivier jeanne
l'ex responsable du centre d'information
europe direct à saint germain en laye et
fiona pickford fondatrice du journal
bilingue le snippet bonsoir à tous les
trois je disais en introduction beaucoup
soulignent le caractère catastrophique
de cette de cette décision de ce choix
britanniques de quitter l'union
européenne pour la première fois un pays
fait fait le choix de revenir en arrière
en quittant l'union alors sommes-nous
tout simplement savoir combien question
sommes-nous tout simplement dans la pire
crise qu'ait connu l'union européenne
depuis la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale philippe le guen on va
commencer avec vous sur votre avis sur
ce constat très pessimiste pour débuter
écoutez ses potes peut-être pas la pire
crise mais c'est quand même une période
difficile pour les européens
une période où un un pays qui est là
quand même depuis 40 ans décide
de manière unilatérale en consultant la
population par un référendum de quitter
l'union européenne donc c'est quelque
chose de complètement nouveau qui ne
s'est jamais vu et qui ouvre une grande
période d'incertitude
olivier jeannois qui sur ce côté un peu
catastrophique que j'énonce pire crise
de l'union européenne depuis la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale est ce que
vous me rejoignent et ou alors vous
mettez ça en perspective
pire crise pire crise danser c'est une
crise parmi tant d'autres bon c'est vrai
que celle là est un peu sévère mais non
c'est une parmi tant d'autres je veux
dire il doit renoncer depuis très
longtemps qui voulait leur faire qui
voulait le faire le référendum donc lots
annoncés mais on n'y croyait pas
forcément c'est ça aussi qui change la
donne du jeu on sait très bien qu un
référendum c'est oui ou non mais on
pensait que ça allait être le in qu'il
allait l'emporter puis finalement ça ne
l'est pas c'est ça aussi le problème
aujourd'hui ça là dessus c'est le
référendum c'est le peuple qui choisit
et on peut pas pronostiquer ce que le
peuple est ce que le peuple va faire
surtout que bon la dernière fois que les
instituts de sondage britannique ont
essayé de pronostiquer quelque chose ils
se sont un peu énormément trompé c'était
sûr là c'était sur l'élection du premier
ministre ont donc fait limpide ford vous
êtes-vous britannique vous êtes dans les
yvelines depuis en france depuis 23 ans
installé dans les yvelines
vous étiez vous en faveur du maintien
dans l'ue pensez vous que c'est la pire
crise que connaît l'union européenne et
puis peut-être votre pays depuis depuis
très longtemps
oui je pense que c'est c'est une crise
assez sérieuse et aussi c'est une crise
pour le royaume uni je pense parce que
le royaume uni est divisée en deux même
nom en plus parce qu'il ya les causes
qui qui a voté pour le monde y rester
pour rester en europe et en russie
latino oui oui 56% c'est et l'irlande du
nord 62% l'ecosse et puis le pays de
galles et l'angleterre qui s'est
prononcé pour le maintien en dehors de
l'union européenne en tout cas enfin le
out
oui oui tout à fait vous vous disiez
récemment dans une interview dans un
article de presse locale vous disiez
être choqué par ce vote ce choix qu'ont
fait vos compatriotes
dix jours plus tard presque deux
semaines plus tard dans quel état
d'esprit vous êtes est-ce que c'est y
est vous avez compris enfin que la
grande bretagne était sortie de l'union
européenne vous l'avez assimilés est-ce
que aussi peut-être vous avez peur de
ses conséquences la pour votre avenir à
vous l'avenir de la bretagne
oui bonne ils disent qu une semaine ces
longues dont les politiques et on va tu
les choses qui se passent à ce moment
c'est il est ils ont ouvert une boîte
qui est plutôt dangereuse et on a peur
mais rien n'est sûr on ne sait pas ce
qui va se passer à ce moment qu'est ce
que vous pensez de l'actualité entre les
têtes d'affiché du livre qui qui tous le
navire boris johnson qui va pas se
présenter pour devenir premier ministre
nigel farage qui était le président liu
qui petit lui aussi qui démissionne
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'on
a menti clairement ouvertement aux
britanniques et qu'on vous a menti à
vous aussi
oui tout à fait ils ont joué avec les
émotions des gens ils ont
cd les arguments étaient plutôt
mensongères et malheureusement les gens
ont cru et mais on voit qu'il n'y avait
pas de plan pas de plomb ils ont ils
n'avaient pas de plan et maintenant il
démissionne donc ils ont sans nul assez
dans une tel état on le disait avec avec
philippe le guen et puis avec olivier
j'aimerais que la question qui se pose
est cette personne ne croyait finalement
au house est ce que vous vous pensiez
aussi que le in allait l'emporter
jusqu'au dernier moment et puis
peut-être aussi vos amis qui vivent en
france quel était votre votre état
d'esprit avant du vote est ce que pour
vous aussi ça a été finalement un tel
choc
est ce que vous aviez envisagé vous
peut-être la sortie
non on pensait que lane va l'emporter
parce que je me suis je me suis couché
la nuit de référendum et c'était plutôt
pour louis et puis on ne se fonde le
matin après c'était vraiment une choc et
j'ai fait un petit sondage sur notre
journal local un en demandant les la vie
des gens est ce que le royaume uni doit
rester dans une union européenne et à la
baisse il t'a était plutôt pour
c'est pas une suprise sur les électeurs
allemands sont plus oui oui merci aussi
sur les gg pas mal de l'acteur français
donc mais c'était 82% pour rester et
puis va me pressent donc ça veut dire
finalement qu'on est dans un pays qui
est qui est réellement divisée entre
peut-être ceux qui sont expatriés entre
des élites intellectuelles ceux qui
vivent dans les grandes villes et puis
le reste du pays alors c'est peut être
vulgarisée schématiser un peu de bruit
est aussi intergénérationnel parce que
beaucoup de gens ont sauté
pour rester en fait les plus âgés ont
voté pour partir on parlait tout à
l'heure philippe le guen et des
mensonges éventuels que la campagne du
livre a pu prononcer pendant tous ces
mois sur les chiffres pour l'argent
donné par la grande bretagne à l'union
européenne finalement se soient avérés
ces chiffres faux est-ce que selon vous
c'est c'est la victoire de la démagogie
en fait il a emporté ben oui c'est c'est
d'une part attiser les peurs donc aussi
d'aider des habitants de la grande
bretagne sur le les étrangers 1 sur les
savez nous n'avons nous avait parlé un
moment du plombier polonais bon il est
en angleterre le plombier polonais ils
travaillent parce qu'il ya besoin de
vois là il a dû travailler là il monte
des entreprises qui sont enregistrés en
grande bretagne et qui sont florissantes
donc c'est plutôt quelque chose de
bénéfique à l'économie britannique est
bien on a réglé dit exactement le
contraire
l'histoire delà de la somme qui est
toutes les semaines devait on devait
payer à 150 millions d'euros
ils sont sûrs qui sonne chapeau une
alors finalement c'était moins en moins
de la moitié d'un puits en plus vous
pouvez pas raisonner comme ça on donne
les pays donne mais reçoivent le fait
d'appartenir à un grand marché ça
apporte aussi beaucoup d'activités les
fonds structurels européens on les
oublie beaucoup je lisais récemment que
la cornouaille par exemple l'ouest de
l'angleterre qui est une zone qui est
prioritaire pour les fonds européens et
qui a voté majoritairement pour le pour
le camp du du du départ de l'union
européenne ce s'interroge maintenant il
se demande si le fait de quitter l'union
européenne va avoir des incidences sur
les fonds européens va évidemment
évidemment donc on ne peut pas avoir le
beurre et l'argent du beurre donc un
moment c'est complètement par un
problème aussi surréaliste quand du lean
qui finalement a fait une campagne très
molle clip le guen puis olivier jeannots
où a éclaté le problème du candu insee
que
quand on dit quelque chose de positif
sur l'union européenne les gens ne
croient pas moins que ça m'arrive tous
les jours aussi en france de dire non
non mais vous coûter vous exagérez
l'union européenne c'est pas bien bon
donc on entend ça tout le temps mais
c'est pas forcément la faute des
personnes qui donnent qui le disent
d'ailleurs c'est c'est parce que depuis
des années
ce message est constamment brocardé par
les hommes politiques par les médias qui
reprennent les hommes politiques
et puis c'est vrai partout on met les
maux de la france généralement l'europe
mais tous les tous les pays font ça
peut-être à l'exception du luxembourg et
encore tous les pays font ça c'est à
dire qu'ils décident des choses en
commun les chefs de gouvernement à
bruxelles et quand ils rentrent chez eux
ils disent c'est pas moi qui les fais on
me l'a imposé c'est bruxelles qui m'a
forcé la main c'est entièrement faux
tous ceux qui se connaissent le
fonctionnement de l'union européenne le
savent mais c'est une minorité de gens
et les autres personnes va finalement
croit tout ce qu'on leur dit depuis des
années quand les tabloïds britanniques
annoncent tous les jours tous les jours
les titres disant que l'union européenne
c'est pas bien faut pas s'étonner quand
même que des gens finissent par voter
olive et jane white sur ce peut-être ce
problème de la campagne du in aussi le
message véhiculé par les hommes
politiques les médias c'est tout
alors sans critiquer le sens critique et
des personnes qui ont mené la campagne
pour le oui parce que quand même c'est
pas un sujet qui fascine
voilà c'était pas la face et finalement
c'est important c'est important alors
après on fait quand on regarde bien ce
que le in a dit si on synthétise grosso
modo le schéma on dit il faut pas sortir
parce que sinon ça va prendre ça va
provoquer une catastrophe économique
donc en fait on va rien changer
voilà grosso modo il ya ça monsieur
cameron avant de faire son référendum
avait notamment négocié auprès l'union
européenne un accord spécifique en
fournissant un statut d'avant encore que
les autres concessions pour la vendre
pas là il ne l'a même pas fait valoir
pendant cette campagne
donc on a aussi eu aussi le camp du in a
été essentiellement sur des arguments
économiques
le fait que par exemple l'union
européenne à la base c'est pour l'apc
pour mettre la fin à la guerre ça que
l'un éléments que les gens oublient
énormément donc le rappel historique
la seule fois que moi je les ai vus dans
la campagne britannique cet élément la
seule fois que je les ai vu c'est quand
il ya une vieille dame à la télé lors de
l' or lors d'un débat public qui disait
ben voilà qui a raconté sa vie et qui a
expliqué pourquoi l'union européenne ce
avait changé sa vie mais voilà c'était
la seule fois précisons que ce
référendum n'est pas contraignant il
n'oblige pas forcément le futur premier
ministre qui sera choisi au mois de
septembre d'entamer la procédure pour
quitter l'union européenne
est ce que vous pensez par exemple fiona
pic record d'aces que vous y croyez ce
que vous voulez que le futur parlement
fin en tout cas le futur premier
ministre ne flanche pas ce processus est
finalement qu'il n'y ait pas de briques
site et qu'on parle de tout ça un peu
pour rien est ce que vous le souhaitez
qu'on aille contre l'avis du peuple
ben je souhaite qu'on reste je souhaite
que qu'il n'invoque pas l'article 50
mais je pense qu'ils vont le faire parce
que c'est très british de
de faire ce qu'on a ce qu'on dit qu'on
va faire et tourisme mais elle a dit
qu'il faudrait faire on rappelle qu'ici
theresa may s'est laissée mourir
ministre actuel qui est pour l'instant
la favorite pour devenir pro vers minuit
elle même faisait plus ou moins enfin
indiqué qu'il faisait campagne pour le
polo in oui elle faisait campagne mais
elle était tout est plutôt peu fils bas
paradoxal on va peut-être mettre à la
tête d'un état qui va quitter l'union
européenne un nouveau premier ministre
qui voudraient qu'ils voulaient y rester
donc on n'a vraiment pas envie de sortir
l'union européenne en fait en bretagne
oui mais mais les autres les leaders du
camping de bauxite ont tous discréditer
ils ont démissionné boston a démissionné
aussi maintenant à geoffrey rush de
youtube et maiko vie qui étaient
partenaires de boris johnson il est
complètement discrédité il a plus de
respect dans sa partie pour ce qu'il a
fait ou la manière dont il faudrait
qu'il a fait vous vous et vous pensez
que c'est ces têtes d'affiché du out se
rend compte finalement que l'attaché est
difficile presque par voire impossible
je pense qu'il jamais jamais pensé en
cours telle était pas une surprise il
avait songé il avait fait pour la propre
intérêt oui philippe le guen est ce que
vous croyez à cette marche arias et
finalement que la grande bretagne va
peut-être rester dans l'union européenne
malgré la décision du peuple britannique
encore une fois c'est vrai ce que dit
madame tout à fait vrai les anglais ont
pour habitude de toujours faire ce
qu'ils ont dit qu'ils à qu'il ferait bon
mais là peut-être vont-ils faire
exception parce que devant l'ampleur de
la tâche sert personne ne sait par où
commencer
il ya 80 mille pages de da qui ce qu'on
appelle les acquis communautaires les
lois européennes si vous voulez qu'il
faut aujourd'hui dans chacune de ces
pages enlevées le royaume uni est
renégociée autre chose ça va prendre des
années personne ne sait faire ça c'est
tellement imbriquées l'union européenne
dans tout ce que nous faisons puisque il
ya ya ya les financements j'ai déjà cité
mais il ya aussi toutes les normes
il ya toutes les règles communes que
nous avons donc dire là je veux pas y
rester mais je veux garder les règles ça
marche pas donc il faut re re faire
autre chose re négocier des traités
renégocier avec chacun des états donc
c'est quelque chose qui semblait un
travail d incroyable affaire qui
prendrait plusieurs années donc je pense
que la démission d'ailleurs de ses
leaders du out montre bien à quel point
non seulement il était non préparés mais
qui n'ont pas d'équipés n'ont même pas
réfléchi à la question pour savoir par
où commencer
donc ils préfèrent évidemment s'en aller
avec le panache enfin pensant avoir un
certain panache disant voilà je mon
travail est fait et je laisse ça
maintenant mes successeurs mais qui sont
ils
personne n'a envie de commencer ce
travail là personne ne sait par où
commencer
olivier jeannots un peu un peu de
pédagogie sur sur la procédure qui va
peut-être commencer à la rentrée
quel est le processus pour une
éventuelle sortie européenne bretagne
alors donc le sait le fameux article 50
du traité sur l'union européenne
alors cet article dit concrètement que
il faut déjà que le chef d'état ou de
gouvernement du pays concerné donc pour
le royaume uni c'est le premier ministre
notifie officiellement l'intention du
royaume uni de quitter l'union
européenne auprès du conseil européen
donc il n'est pas obligé de le faire et
pour l'instant on ne l'a pas fait voilà
c'est pour le sait les britanniques qui
décide finalement quand est ce qui
ressort c'est bb avoir des pressions
politiques ou des scellés britannique
qui dès qu'ils décident de quand est ce
qu'ils veulent sortir une fois qu'ils
ont une fois qu'ils ont une fois qu'ils
ont notifié leurs droits de vote au sein
du conseil européen et du conseil de
l'union européenne au niveau de l'union
européenne est suspendu et à partir de
là en train dé s'ouvre alors un délai de
deux ans par défaut ou on va essayer
effectivement de liquider tout l'acquis
communautaire
quatre-vingt mille pages de législation
et aussi de sang traités internationaux
donc c'est pas rien donc là si on
commence en septembre 2016 imaginons on
est parti pour septembre 2018 alors par
défaut
quatre-vingt mille pages de législation
je suis juriste à la base je fais passer
en deux ans les membres 2020 2022 les au
petit lait on partirait plutôt sur dix
ans pour les 10 ans voilà c'est dit on
dans un flou finalement fait pour pour
les britanniques comme fiona pickford ce
que c'est ça aussi ce nouvel accord que
vont passer les européens avec la grande
bretagne c'est ce qui va permettre de
définir les règles entre les relations
économiques les bizarres et pour
l'instant c'est pas pour le moment en
fait il n'ya pas de flou parce que tant
que la procédure de l'article 50 n'est
pas fini la législation européenne
continue à s'appliquer
c'est à dire que pour le moment le
royaume uni est toujours membre de
l'union européenne
il a toujours voix au sein du conseil de
l'union européenne les fonds européens
continuent à s'appliquer continuent à
s'appliquer dans les différentes régions
britanniques à bord de l'eurostar pour
aller en cause leur statut les lois
européennes continuent à s'appliquer
donc pour pour moment je veux dire d'un
point de vue juridique on essaye donc ça
peut durer de 10 ans comme ça ça peut
durer dix ans et donc justement c'est
pour ça qu'on a prévu à la base cette
période où on va renégocier les accords
tout en maintenant en fait justement la
législation européenne
en vigueur parce que tout simplement
effectivement le statut des
ressortissants britanniques qui sont en
dehors de l'union européenne si on
décide de couper tout d'un coup comme ça
la législation européenne
ça veut juste dire qu'il se retrouve en
situation irrégulière et donc au bout de
six mois il faut les éjecter et les
faire rentrer chez eux de force manu
militari
fiona pu forcer c'est justement un sujet
qui j'imagine doit vous préoccupez vous
vos amis ici en france sur ce côté
qu'est ce que vous allez devenir quel
droit vous allez avoir un futur
oui j'irai chercher un partenariat des
plus on va dire des plus poussée entre
la le reste de l'union européenne et la
grande bretagne
bah oui je pense que tout le monde pense
que peut-être il va négocier
un accord comme la norvège ou la suisse
où on fait partie et de l'espace
économique européenne et mai et à ce
moment là on a la possibilité d'avoir
l'accès ou bien de marcheprime movement
libre circulation des biens voilà voilà
c'est ça et aussi je pense pas que notre
statut va changer mais qui sait tu t'es
tu t es négocier et je pense que
peut-être moi en tant que je me sens
européenne mais peut-être pour moi et
aussi en tant que gérante d'une société
peut-être c'est ça va être le moment de
demander la nationalité française
peut-être libéré depuis depuis tout à
l'heure on parle de multiples aspects
négatifs du bric site
mais on peut y voir aussi l'occasion de
relancer l'union européenne écoutez à ce
propos pierre l'écuyer députée yvelinois
et président d'île de france europe il
était il y a quelques jours sur ce
plateau même il faut absolument en faire
une opportunité puisque la grande
bretagne s'en va eh bien faisons de la
zone euro une zone beaucoup plus forte
beaucoup plus audacieuse sur les thèmes
qui intéressent les citoyens c'est à
dire la croissance et d'emploi alors on
a fait le plan donc c'est bien mais il
faudrait qu'on ait une politique commune
de l'industrie une politique commune de
l'énergie une politique commune de la
recherche et donc il faut qu'on mette à
la tête de la zone euro un président
stable
qu'ils soient qui soit responsable de la
gouvernance économique aussi et puis la
troisième chose ce qu'il faut parfois
exagérée à une critique parfois exagéré
mais que l'europe se détourne des
problèmes de détail des normes
excessive et ça c'est facile à faire
il ya des systèmes qui sont mis en place
la comitologie fjep à entrer dans les
détails qui font que des décisions peu
démocratiques sont prises sur des points
finalement tout à fait secondaires comme
la taille des haies des paniers de pêche
ou et c'est à ça il faut laisser tomber
complètement ça pour bien montrer qu'on
s'occupe des problèmes réels des
européens alors pierre lequiller parle
de plus d'europe sur par exemple la
recherche l'industrie l'énergie et moins
d'europe peut-être sur des choses plus
farfelues est ce que ce serait pas mal
pour un bien le break cité pour relancer
le processus européen qui est au point
mort maintenant depuis depuis depuis
très longtemps peut-être depuis
maastricht
écoutez pourquoi elle est au point mort
parce que les états ne voulait pas
avancer bon pierre lequiller je le
connais et les jeux fait respectable il
a été à l'assemblée nationale le
responsable de 2 des affaires
européennes la commission parlementaire
des affaires européennes mais bon on
sait très bien que c'est sans la volonté
d aider des gouvernements des états et
bien justement l'europe ne s'occupe de
ce que ce que des domaines qu'on lui
laisse en pâture c'est à dire en effet
la taille des concombres puisqu'il y
avait que ça à s'occuper puisque les les
autres questions fondamentales les états
membres à chaque fois mettre leur veto
et ne veulent pas avancer alors moi je
veux bien que le break site nous donne
l'occasion d'aller vers plus
d'intégration et c'est lui c'est à eux
maintenant de se dire si nous ne voulons
pas d'autres pays qui qui font l'exit
qui sortent en effet mettons nous autour
de la table et travaillons sur les vrais
sujets d'importance mais voilà ça ne
viendra pas tout seul c'est pas l'europe
qu'est ce que c'est l'europe sont les
états voilà donc
et pour le moment bombe à tout le monde
et un petit peu tétanisé tout le monde
ne sait pas trop quoi faire en parle
dans son coin entre la merkel qui dit
voyons entre françois hollande semble
pouvoir justement lancé un processus
avec matteo renzi on a un peu et puis
les pays de l'est qui sont qui
rejoignent également d un peu tétanisé
personne ne s'attendait à cela
et puis on attend de voir aussi ce que
ça a comme conséquence économique y
compris sur les autres pays qui ont des
entreprises et qu'ils ont démarché en
grande bretagne c'est ça la question
aujourd'hui olivier jeanne vox sûr sur
cette question là est ce que ça peut
être une bonne nouvelle finalement vous
vous partagez j'imagine le point de vue
de philippe le guen sur le fait que ce
soit finalement un chef d'état qui
tienne si effectivement on n'a pas de
politique de la recherche et parce que
les chefs d'etas ne se mettent pas
d'accord je veux dire au niveau de
l'union européenne qu'on veut agir sur
une politique on met des financements le
problème c'est que nous notre budget
hors pair il en baisse parce que tout
simplement les chefs d'état ont voulu
eux ont décidé qu'il fallait réduire
donc ça c'est déjà un premier élément
donc oui il va falloir que les chefs
d'état se mettent d'accord entre après
là où je serai peut-être un peu plus
optimistes c'est que au niveau de
l'union européenne sur beaucoup de
domaines
sur certains domaines on était obligé
décidé à l'unanimité sur d'autres on
était obligé de décider à la majorité
qualifiée et alors on avait notamment ce
qu'on appelait nous les minorités
d'abstention sépare c'est à dire qu'à
partir d'un moment où un certain nombre
d'états des deux décident de dire ben
voilà stock on va pas aller plus loin on
arrête on ne décide pas en la matière on
va dire que les britanniques étaient les
champions en la matière et qui arrivait
un peu a observé un peu de porte
étendard
maintenant que les britanniques sont
sortis maintenant si si il est si ils
sortent officiellement complètement donc
on va devoir prendre les décisions à 27
ça sera déjà un peu moins compliqué et
c'est que surtout tous les petits états
qui ont tous les petits états où tous
les états qui en fait est un était un
peu me chaut me froid qui savait pas
trop où se positionner ils vont être
obligés de se positionner parce que soit
vu que maintenant le royaume uni ne sera
plus là pour faire un épouvantail 20
soit ils sont pour soi ils sont contre
beaucoup parlent aussi dans la presse
les spécialistes du couple du fameux
couple franco-allemand c'est lui qui
devrait prendre l'initiative pour
relancer le processus européen est ce
qu'aujourd'hui ce couple fonctionne et
ce qui semble marcher on sait qu'il ya
des élections qui arrivent dans les deux
pays en 2017
on est parti là aussi pour au moins une
année de pas de rien écoutez le couple
franco allemand oui on n'aurait pas leur
optimiste et sarko non parce que le
couple franco-allemand ça fait des
années s'est passé depuis très longtemps
en avril qu'il fonctionnait avec des
dératés parce qu'une api il n'a pas là
les français les allemands n'ont pas la
même vision socialiste en france
oui mais indépendamment de ça on a déjà
eu des présidents socialistes et
conservateurs et conservateurs et qui
sont tant des biens mais ils étaient ils
avaient la même vision sur la relance
économique sur ce qu'il faut faire et
c'est sur la réduction de la dette
il a vraiment cette sont deux opposés
d'ailleurs de temps en temps les grandes
la grande-bretagne servait dans un sens
comme dans l'autre c'est à dire que pour
dans ce couple il y avait des v1
finalement un triangle amoureux avec la
grande bretagne et qui tantôt servait
damman
merkel est tantôt de maîtresse à
monsieur hollande sur les certains ce
moment ils seront en face à face voilà
ils vont être en face à face bon
peut-être vont-ils trouver un autre un
autre bouc émissaire aussi apprendre
entre les deux je ne sais pas on arrive
déjà à la fin de cette émission merci à
tous les trois d'y avoir participé
une émission que vous pouvez retrouver
en podcast sur tv fil 78 points comme
bonne soirée à tous